new fighting in Syria threatens a
russian-backed humanitarian pause in the
battle for a rebel-held area near the
country's capital the eastern Goethe
district outside Damascus has faced a
deadly bombing campaign by the Syrian
government rush up Syria's most powerful
ally ordered the daily five-hour pause
in the fighting more than 500 people
have died in eastern glutens last week
Seth Doane is now in Damascus South good
morning good morning government-held
areas of Damascus have also been shelled
by rebels lobbing mortars and it was
reports of shelling on those
humanitarian quarters today that may
have for today to evacuate civilians
syrian state TV reporter was on live
near one of the corridors when there was
an explosion footage shows the road
meant to be carrying evacuated civilians
from gouta has been quiet this morning
the plan had been to allow them to
escape this the barrage of airstrikes
bombs and shelling that have pounded
this part of the capital for more than a
week it was a bit quieter overnight
ahead of the planned russian-backed
five-hour pause but reports from this
hell on earth are dire the white helmets
posted this video of at least two small
children being carried from the rubble
of their home they asked where is mom
the UN estimates as many as
three-quarters of private homes have
been damaged so civilians have sought
refuge and cramped underground shelters
where hospitals are still standing they
can't provide much help
a Syrian doctor describes a catastrophic
situation at her field hospital with the
exhausted hungry medical staff operating
with depleted stocks and seeing the
unimaginable dead bodies of terrible
wounds while hearing bombs dropping
nearby those here in government-held
areas of Damascus are also tired and
weary of this war we were with one
fifteen-year-old boy last night as he
checked Facebook to see if school would
be open today it wouldn't have been
closed for weather reasons but
war gale way thank you very much Seth
Doane reporting from Damascus